coming into land in new york the uk
prime minister's first trip overseas
since the start of the pandemic
back to the city of his birth for the
united nations general assembly a global
gathering of politicians facing global
challenges and the pm tasks with trying
to galvanize action on perhaps the
biggest of them all climate change
this is a crucial summit absolutely
crucial uh for the the next couple of
months it's it's only a couple of months
now till uh the cop 26 summit and so we
need everybody to focus on what's called
their nationally determined
contributions that's the amount of
carbon dioxide each country is going to
is going to cut the uk is
way out in front or well is doing very
well we've made a big big pledge we've
already greatly reduced our our co2 but
we need other countries to step up to
the plate uh the big emitters around the
world
the u.s one of those emitters and the pm
here to line up hard cash but nothing is
guaranteed boris johnson is known for
his tendency to over promise but at this
critical summit in new york which one
officials described to me as an
important staging post on the way to cop
he's been
uncharacteristically downbeat about the
prospect of securing financial
commitments from other developed nations
to help tackle climate change
perhaps he's learnt the art of
expectation management
more likely he knows just how difficult
truly global agreement will be
relations between boris johnson and joe
biden have been strained in recent weeks
over the chaotic evacuation from kabul
this their first face-to-face meeting
since the withdrawal and a test of the
pm's diplomacy when bush comes to such
of mr johnson is a tough pragmatic
politician who knows how to get from a
to b and in that respect
not many people might admit it in that
respect he's not dissimilar
to
president biden from the nhs and social
care plan to the cabinet reshuffle the
pm has set out his domestic agenda in
the past few weeks
this week here his attention turns to
international ambitions
beth rigby sky news new york